station this is wired how do you hear me
we hear you loud and clear these
questions that I'm going to ask came
from Google autocomplete so this is what
the people would like to know do
astronauts drink Tang I don't think we
have tang specifically onboard but we do
have lots of fruit juices and coffees
and teas and water and even no milk do
astronauts drink their own pee well
thank you for asking us to repeat these
questions in a sense yes we take the the
condensate that the system collects up
the urine and all that gets processed
and then put out of a portable water
dispenser which is right over our head
so everyday that's pretty much what we
do can keep their suits unfortunately
not know our spacesuits and quite
valuable pieces of equipment can
astronauts cry in space of course
astronauts can cry in space you know the
water in space is different because it
sticks to your skin it's almost like
like this gluey substance that just has
this ability to stick to your skin so if
you were to have a really big cry then
your eyes would just swell up with water
and stead of it dropping off can
astronauts wear glasses of course they
can wear glasses jeff has his glasses on
right now I'm wearing contact lenses
young tim peake doesn't need glasses but
we surely can't wear them
can we whistle on the moon the real
question is can we whistle in a space
suit and it can be very difficult
actually when you're outside doing a
spacewalk and it would be the same on
the moon because in that in that case
you're breathing 100% oxygen which means
you're at a much lower pressure so when
you're at a lower pressure
whistling becomes a little bit more
challenging we certainly can whistle
here the astronauts need passports when
we come home we do need passports
because we land in Kazakhstan and we
have to go through customs and so our
ground team makes sure that we have our
passport so that we can actually leave
Kazakhstan and go back to America when
we're done
the astronauts vote in space yes we can
vote in space in fact NASA has been very
good about setting up a process so that
we can participate in the electoral
process these national as where diapers
yes is the answer to that question when
we launched in the Soyuz we have at
least a couple of hours before launch
sitting in that spacecraft and then we
have to go through a 6-hour rendezvous
and then we have to spend a couple of
hours from docking until actually
getting on board the space stations also
wear diapers when we go outside the
space station to a spacewalk we could
suspend anything from eight to ten hours
inside that spacesuit sometimes longer
so with the joven to take precautions
and wear diapers just in case you need
to use it
as thoughts can drink alcohol when we're
training on the ground or planet Earth
but alcohol is not permitted onboard the
space station and astronauts have
piercings I'm pretty sure there have
been some of the female astronauts that
have been up here the ladies that have
had pierced ears and that kind of thing
other than that I don't I'm not aware of
any but I'm also not aware of any
restrictions so but I would suggest if
somebody gets a piercing they do it on
the ground not here can humans colonize
Mars of course we can colonize Mars it's
a it's both a technical and a political
question because it would take
tremendous amount of resources and that
has to have the political will and the
funding to do that and then I'll
obviously we need to develop the
technology both to get there quickly
land on the planet and then be able to
live there but I'm certain that someday
we'll be able to see that hopefully in
our lifetime station this is Houston ACR
thank you that concludes the event thank
you have a great day